[Musique]
vous êtes en quatrième les profs on ait
personne pour vous dire si vous allez
réussir votre vie ou pas moi j'en sais
rien ce que vous allez dans dix ans
[Musique]
je crois qu apparemment je vais
commencer une liste de ceux déjà
réalisés mais moi j'aime [ __ ] mais moi
c'est des rêves fous apg
j'ai juste peur de ne pas réussir ce que
j'entreprends je fasse parce qu'on a pas
tous un talent est là tu as envie de
pleurer quand tu vois ta tête par une
pleurer mais quand je suis stressée
j'arrive plus à rien donc si tu veux
faire ça que j'ai zéro à cause de toi ça
va aller au franchement c'est la pire
année de ma vie je serai encore plus
jolie si tu perdais un peu de poids
debout
mais la rigueur par téléphone et même
les filles alors j -c et respectueux
pourquoi c'est quel âge l'âge idéal pour
ça pour la première fois non parce que
j'aimerais dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça allait devoir réfléchir aux choix qui
va être le vôtre
je pense que je suis plus attiré par les
personnes âgées de mieux comprendre les
choses
dans cette période si douloureuse pour
notre pays la france est forte elle se
lève toujours disant que ça ne te
laissent aucune halte jusqu'à ce que je
vais faire [ __ ] on s'en fout tu vas
partir à paris moi je vais partir sur
limoges ces cantons ce qu'on verra on
aura gras changer toute voix et
angoissant je trouve le futur en vrai
m
[Musique]